les québecois envoient près d'un million de tonnes de
matière aux centres de recyclage
une partie de votre bac va effectivement
loin jusqu'en inde
divers sacs et emballages plastiques
imprimés avec des marques connues
cachemire
euh
et ce qui se passe après n'est pas tout à fait ce que
le gouvernement m'a promis
est-ce légal de brûler
le plastique comme ça avec le bois
pas une sorte de diamant
comment le plastique va-t-il de nos
bacs de recyclage aux dépotoirs de l'autre côté de
la planète où il est souvent brûlé
pour découvrir que nous avons suivi un
approvisionnement international opaque  chaîne et faire la
lumière sur une réalité cachée et inquiétante
peu de gens savaient qu'avant 2018
comme celle d'une grande partie de l'ouest, une grande
partie de nos déchets était exportée pour être
recyclée vers la chine avec son
économie en pleine croissance l'appétit de la chine pour les
déchets recyclables semblait insatiable alors que les
réglementations et  les exigences de qualité
étaient minimales les matériaux envoyés étaient mal
triés ou souvent difficiles à recycler
mais il y a quatre ans la chine a décidé que
le social a  nd les coûts environnementaux étaient
trop lourds
el mundo
nous sommes en crise
les ondes de choc se faisaient sentir partout d'
énormes tas de déchets sont apparus dans les
centres de tri qui ont crié au secours
[Musique]
nous commençons par une question
est ce que notre plastique pollue encore les
pays les plus pauvres
sont  nous exportons toujours notre problème
ailleurs c'est là que commence le recyclage nos bacs
vont à un centre de tri
tierra présidé jusqu'à récemment
qui exploite le centre de tri à
sherbrooke québec
depuis 2018 des efforts majeurs ont été faits
pour recycler plus de matériaux au canada
mais un produit qui partait  aller en
chine est devenu un vrai casse tête voir
ce qu'ils aiment seo ils peuvent utiliser leur
nom plus
ils sucent le plastique les
plus envolés des centres au québec ne
savent plus quoi faire de tous ces
sacs et emballages en plastique qui en principe
doivent être recyclés et leur parcours semble
pour finir ici
en 2019 seulement 3 de plastique souple qui a
relativement peu de valeur a été recyclé au
canada
marque olivier a consacré son professio
vie finale au recyclage, il est professeur et
chercheur en gestion des déchets,
mais où à l'étranger
pour trouver de la chance
une fois que les matières recyclables sont vendues à des courtiers,
elles entrent dans un courant de commerce international
et leur piste est en grande partie perdue
notre enquête a heurté un mur,
ce sont les découvertes de  un
inspecteur belge qui a changé le cours de notre
enquête
son travail nous a montré que les déchets plastiques
voyagent encore longtemps mais cachés dans un
emballage différent
le port d'anvers est le deuxième
plus grand d'europe après rotterdam
mark destrooper est inspecteur environnemental
au port c'est  un
point de transit clé pour les navires et les marchandises
voyageant entre l'amérique du nord et l'asie,
nous l'avons contacté car dans un obscur
rapport international, nous avons découvert qu'il
avait intercepté plusieurs envois de
papier mixte canadien de quatre
entreprises différentes en 2019 et 2020
et c'est pourquoi il les a arrêtés.
attiré notre attention,
les factures papier étaient contaminées par de
grandes quantités illégales de  autres
déchets principalement du plastique
deux jours avant notre arrivée il a arrêté
20 conteneurs de papier mixte du
port de montréal à
destination de l'inde
il a accepté de nous en ouvrir un
[Musique]
euh
étranger
pour lui ce sont des déchets mixtes qui ne peuvent pas
être exportés vers  des pays comme l'inde
sans leur consentement préalable le
strooper renverra cette expédition au canada
il estime qu'il y a environ 25
contaminations
dans ces balles
la limite indienne n'est que de 2 pour cent
25 pour cent ne signifieront probablement pas grand chose pour
vous mais dans le monde du recyclage  c'est
énorme le
tri est la clé du recyclage et
plus les produits sont propres et
homogènes plus il est facile de les recycler
et
de les revendre  l'un
des plus grands au québec
le centre appartient à une entreprise appelée
rikova rikova est un acteur majeur dans le
monde du recyclage
au québec l'entreprise gère thr  ee
centres de tri dont deux dans la
ville de montréal
um
notre planète
[Musique]
pourquoi les balles de papier de montréal
qui ont été interceptées à anvers contenaient
autant de plastique
plastique pour trier le plastique
lors de l'ouverture d'un nouveau centre de tri en
novembre de  2019 la ville de montréal a
promis qu'elle produirait des
matériaux de qualité
la haute responsable montréalaise pour
les questions environnementales n'a pas voulu
regarder la vidéo que nous avons tournée devant
notre caméra nous avons dû la lui montrer
avant l'entrevue et c'est là que les
choses se compliquent
[Musique]
et
mais cela ne devrait pas surprendre car
la ville reçoit des rapports mensuels sur la
qualité des matériaux qui sortent du
centre de tri et les chiffres que la ville de
montréal nous a donné correspondent à ceux de l'
inspecteur belge papier mélangé du
centre de tri semi-coque  a eu un
taux de contamination de 26 l'an dernier
mais pour le président du groupe rikova
ce problème de forte contamination
n'existe tout simplement pas et il s'interroge sur
la c  les methodes de calcul utilisees par la ville
en nouvelle zelande
il s'agit
d'un vrai trio quebec sauf que les
chiffres cites de recherche quebec
datent de 2019 peu apres la crise
causee par la chine nous avons appele 12
centres de tri dont le plus grand au quebec
et ils pretent etre bien en dessous  ce
taux aujourd'hui dû aux investissements dans la
technologie mais une chose est certaine la
contamination détectée par l'
inspecteur belge marcus trooper est si élevée qu'il
a refusé de laisser partir les containers
vers l'inde dominique culubriali cependant
conteste aussi les numéros de ce trooper
[Musique]
c'est un  acheteur majeur d'autres
entreprises canadiennes également
et c'est là que nous sommes allés voir ce
qu'il advient de ces factures
nous avons quitté la capitale new delhi et nous nous sommes dirigés
vers muzaffar nagar
une ville avec une forte concentration de
factures papier
nous nous concentrons maintenant sur la
capitale indienne où  plus de 20 millions de
personnes continuent de respirer de l'air toxique
au début du mois de novembre la pollution de l'air a atteint
des niveaux critiques combinés  avec la
brume matinale
des dernières semaines, une épaisse couche
d'habitants du smog se plaignant d'
allergies, de larmoiements et même de
maladies respiratoires avant d'arriver, nous avons identifié
les usines de muzaffar naga qui
importent du papier canadien pour le recyclage,
y compris le papier de ricoba,
nous avons localisé des zones à proximité
[Musique]
même  ce sac de lait du québec que nous avons
vu à l'épicerie est ici
[Musique]
nous avons vu beaucoup de déchets européens et américains
mais c'était le plastique canadien qui
semblait prédominer les matériaux qu'on nous
a dit provenir d'une papeterie voisine
qui les transfère pour le tri  aux
sous-traitants
[Musique]
un groupe de femmes est arrivé
ce plastique d'où vient-il
et le travail acharné commence
alors
pouvez-vous m'expliquer le travail que vous
faites ici que faites-vous
votre mot de passe
c'est un peu plus de trois dollars canadiens par
jour les
trieurs se séparent  doux à partir de plastique dur, le
plastique plus dur sera vendu et
probablement recyclé
pour prendre un peu d'avance, ils espèrent trouver
des billets de banque étrangers bu  t ceux-ci sont souvent
déchirés
cela vient du
canada et cela vient des états-unis
amérique
juste à côté se trouve un autre
terrain où nous avons vu encore plus de tas de
déchets une sorte de mine à ciel ouvert d'où le
plastique est extrait et ici aussi nous
trouvé beaucoup d'emballages canadiens il
y a même des sacs réutilisables provenant d'
endroits reconnaissables, y compris un sac de recyclage de la ville de toronto
dans trois autres sites que nous avons visités plus tard,
nous avons été surpris par la grande
quantité de déchets canadiens que nous avons trouvés
et d'où vient le plastique souple qui
est jeté  et mis de côté go quand on
demande aux trieurs ils ont dit qu'ils
ne savaient pas mais cet ouvrier nous a dit qu'une
partie du plastique retournait dans les
usines
pour l'instant c'est tout ce qu'il nous dirait
ces ouvriers sont au fond d'un
écosystème construit  autour de l'industrie du papier
muzaffar nagar a 30 usines de ce type nous avons
rapidement découvert que ces usines
étaient très controversées les
villageois nous ont dit qu'une fois trié
le plastique souple importé n'est pas  recyclé
loin de là on nous a dit que certaines
papeteries brûlaient une partie de ce plastique pour
générer de l'énergie thermique pour leurs chaudières
afin d'échapper à la détection les gens ici disent
qu'ils le font discrètement la nuit comme
le montre cette vidéo amateur
raul kumar est un agriculteur qui voulait
prouver  à nous que les papeteries brûlaient du
plastique illégalement
il nous a emmenés dans ces champs près des
usines où des camions arrivaient pour décharger les
cendres éliminées par l'industrie
et au pied de ces montagnes grises
des restes calcinés de plastique
est un biologiste qui vit à surabaya dans
le  partie orientale de l'
île indonésienne de java
une région avec de nombreuses papeteries son
enquête a commencé en 2017 lorsque la chine a
annoncé qu'elle resserrait les
règles de recyclage
c'est alors qu'il a commencé à voir de grandes
quantités de plastique étranger apparaître
autour de lui une grande question pour nous  pourquoi vous, en
tant
qu'entreprise de papier, vous avez beaucoup de
déchets plastiques dans notre quartier,
il a décidé de vérifier le
numéro deux, nous utilisons un drone
usi  ng fil pour voir les pilules de poivre
et puis nous
ouais nous allons à l'intérieur pour venir à l'usine
je
[Musique]
parle avec le directeur
et ils disent que oui depuis 2017 nous
avons beaucoup de
plastique
à l'intérieur du papier porte les impuretés
est généralement moins que  10 pour cent
[Musique]
mais 2017 est de 30 à 40, c'est du plastique
comme une maison de Troie vous le mettez
le plastique à l'intérieur des factures papier ici
parce qu'il n'y a
pas de réglementation
acos de los pacity à travers le fl
le commerce international des déchets est
le domaine d'expertise de l'avocat david azzullah
juste  comme en inde,
krigi a trouvé du plastique de mauvaise qualité
extrait des balles de papier qui
étaient brûlées,
mais ici, il a été utilisé comme carburant pour aider à
fabriquer quelque chose de
tofu surprenant. C'est une pratique inquiétante en 2019.
jeune
tarentule
étrangère
après avoir fait ses découvertes a
alerté les autorités sur tout le
papier contaminé qui était
importé
et le gouvernement a commencé à craquer
en indonésie,
il a également protesté devant plusieurs
ambassades à jakarta
aujourd'hui,
je veux
renvoyer à l'
ambassade américaine,
nous n'avons pas besoin de ce
moment
trois ans plus tard, il attend toujours la
réponse du canada,
mais des pays comme le canada avaient déjà
commencé à  déplacer leurs exportations vers
des marchés plus accommodants comme l'inde
et là aussi les gens s'inquiètent de l'
impact de ce commerce sur leur santé
et voient cette feuille
comment elle se couvre de cendre comme ça et
le réel est ce
ce type de cendre 12 à 13 particules minuscules
particules  est entré dans mes yeux
et le médecin a dit
et vous pouvez je ne vois rien
niya tomar est une championne internationale de tir
et ses yeux sont ce qui est le plus important
dans son sport
mais il y a deux ans, elle a commencé à avoir de
sérieux problèmes
elle blâme les cendres qui sortent de  les
papeteries
tout autour de l'école de tir
nia et sa mère reena ont même fait campagne
lors des dernières élections municipales
dans l'espoir d'arrêter une partie de cette
pollution
a f  À quelques kilomètres de sa terre se trouve ce
canal dans un cadre moins que pittoresque
et sur ses bords
se trouve le village de bandura on nous a dit
que les papeteries étaient en grande partie
responsables de l'eau sale dans le
canal
étranger
plus près de l'usine l'eau est
presque complètement  recouvert d'une croûte sale
dans plusieurs villages proches des
usines, on nous a dit qu'il y avait une
incidence plus élevée de maladies qui, selon les habitants
, sont liées à la pollution à shang. Le
pauvre raul kumar et ses amis ont même
commencé à collecter des dossiers médicaux.
l'asthme les maladies de la peau et les cancers
même les villages les plus anciens étaient pour la plupart silencieux
maintenant je voulais parler
c'est pour le rein
et si une chose est claire pour tout le monde
ici c'est que la combustion du plastique est un
contributeur majeur à leurs
problèmes de santé
nous avons également vérifié
ces dernières années les papeteries  comme
les fabricants de briques et de sucre ont été condamnés à une amende
pour avoir brûlé clandestinement du plastique
le jour de notre arrivée, nous avons remarqué  près
de l'un des dépotoirs de plastique, de la fumée noire
sortant d'un petit bâtiment,
on nous a dit que le bâtiment faisait du jaggery un
sucre raffiné populaire dans la région,
beaucoup de ces petites entreprises utilisent le
plastique comme carburant,
alors ce qu'elles font, c'est qu'elles prennent du bois
et qu'elles prennent  le plastique et ils le
brûlent ensemble oh ouais est-ce
légal de brûler
le plastique comme ça avec le bois
pas une sorte de vitamine
mais les gens le font quand même
ouais à côté du four il y a un tas de
bois et un tas de plastique plus petit
dedans  devant la caméra bien que le travailleur
ne brûle que du bois
et que sa famille possède plusieurs usines à
muzaffar nagar et qu'il soit le président
de l'association locale des papeteries
malgré les preuves recueillies, il nous a assuré
que son industrie dispose légalement de
tout le plastique récupéré que
nous
donnons  à cette cimenterie
chaque mois
environ
30 40 50 ou 70 tonnes nous la donnons à
la cimenterie ils l'utilisent pour la combustion
d'une
manière respectueuse de l'environnement
cela ne crée aucun problème  vous pensez que les
gens au canada devraient se sentir bien à propos de
ce qui se passe oui donc c'est une erreur de la part de
peu d'autorités parce que j'ai vu des
amendes et des raids et tout ça euh
c'est un malentendu
que puis-je dire
mais les assurances de l'industrie ne font pas grand-chose pour
convaincre les villageois locaux
quatre village  les chefs ont récemment exigé
des actions concrètes sur la combustion des
déchets plastiques
le gouvernement selon eux intervient de
temps en temps mais les usines ont vite
repris leurs mauvaises habitudes
pour l'avocat david azule la
crise chinoise a été une occasion manquée qui
aurait pu être mise à profit pour réparer le commerce mondial des
déchets
[Musique]
le jour où nous avons quitté
le mur de smog toxique commençait à
s'estomper l'
inde a l'une des pires
pollutions de l'air sur terre
rina et raul nous ont demandé pourquoi des pays
comme le canada ont des
étrangers
[musique]
[musique] de
retour
au collège sorel  tracy marc olivier
forme les futurs techniciens en
hygiène et sécurité de l'environnement
dans l'émission d'aujourd'hui recyclage
vous
on lui a montré des photos du cana
déchets indiens que nous avons trouvés en inde
la ville défend rikova en disant qu'elle
n'a repris le centre de coquillages sami qu'en
2020.
michelle
nous avons réalisé que la ville ignorait
que l'envoi de factures avec
des niveaux de contamination de 25% en inde était
illégal
[musique]
seulement
dans tous les cas  dit que le chef de l'environnement
montréal n'a aucun contrôle légal une fois que les
matières recyclables sont exportées
sur une enceinte et non sous contrat
il y a une réelle tension entre
les parties du marché libre et les préoccupations environnementales
cela pourrait éventuellement être résolu si quelqu'un
vérifiait ce qui est arrivé à notre recyclage
une fois qu'il a quitté le pays
mais en ce moment  pas de niveau
selon la ville ce sont des
gens d'affaires comme dominique columbriali qui assument
une partie de cette responsabilité les
données d'experts en importation obtenues par anket
révèlent que 500 000 tonnes de
papier mixte canadien ont été exportées vers l'inde
entre 2019 et 2021
rikova a exporté la moitié de cette quantité
son président  dit qu'il ne peut pas contrôler
ce qui se passe en Inde
partenaire italien ils disent
comme le pa  Le porte-parole de Per Mills en
Inde, il dit que si le plastique est brûlé, les
gens le font légalement,
en particulier
certains plastiques sont en fait brûlés dans
des conditions environnementales plus contrôlées
dans les cimenteries, mais cela reste une
pratique controversée
et nous avons parlé à de nombreux travailleurs et
villageois qui nous ont dit  que certaines
industries se débarrassent de ce plastique de
manière plus dangereuse
mis au courant des résultats de notre
enquête le ministre de l'environnement du canada
reconnaît que les entreprises
ne devraient pas exporter des déchets hautement contaminés
de l'exportation de la pollution
l'exportation
est afin de réduire la dépendance du canada sur
les marchés internationaux provinciaux et
les gouvernements fédéraux parient principalement
que le canada fabriquera moins de
plastique à l'avenir, mais les
règles gouvernementales concernant ce plan sont encore dans des
années, en attendant, marcus trooper
tentera d'arrêter le flux de déchets sales
même s'il n'en attrape qu'une infime partie
depuis notre visite  en octobre dernier, il a attrapé
quatre autres cargaisons illégales ou  originaires
de différentes provinces du canada
depuis 2016 123
contenants de papier plastique ou de
déchets domestiques ont été retournés au canada de
six pays différents
l'amende
six lettres d'avertissement
et le ministère de l'environnement
ne dira pas à quelles entreprises il les a envoyés
l'arpentage
étranger